bill so the key is to recognize that
it's in that quadratic form and you can
do that by looking at the middle term if
you notice that that middle terms
exponent is half of that leading terms
exponent then you know you've got a
quadratic trinomial on your hands so say
for example number two you can see this
is X plus 3 to the first this is X plus
3 squared notice that this middle
exponent is half of this leading terms
exponent same thing here you have X to
the fourth that's half of ec4 is half of
8 so we know it's a in quadratic forms
now there's two different methods one
method is where you can make a U
substitution so I'll show you that
method first what you do is you let u
equal that middle group so I'm going to
say let u equal X to the one-half power
and so now if we let u equal X to the
one-half power we have minus u minus
twelve and this is going to be U squared
because if you think about U squared
equals x to the one-half to the second
power power to power you multiply it
that's going to give you actually to the
first so now when we look at this it's
much easier to recognize and much easier
to factor you can see that this is going
to be u minus four times u plus three
notice the negative four times positive
three gives us negative twelve the
negative for u and the positive three
you add up to the middle term negative
one u and then u times u is u squared
now at this point since everything was
in terms of X not u you can go back and
say well hmm u equals x to the one-half
let me put that back in place of U so X
to the one-half minus four and X to the
one-half plus three now if you wanted to
take it one step further if this was an
equation like it was equal to zero then
you could take each group and set each
group equal to zero and solve that
equation let's go to example number two
see if you can not do this one so this
one what I would do if I was doing a u
substitution as I would say let u equal
this middle group here X plus three so
that means that we have minus 2-u minus
fifteen and then this is U squared so
now all we have to do is say what two
quantities multiply to negative fifteen
but add to negative two and we can see
that's going to be
negative 5 and positive 3 because we
know that U is equal to X plus 3 we can
put that back in place of you okay so X
plus 3 minus 5 and this would be X plus
3 plus 3 which simplifies down to X
minus 2 and X plus 6 so they've got that
one now let's look at number three the
last one at this point you probably
couldn't recognize a quicker way of
doing this you can say to yourself well
Who am I recognize that X to the fourth
is half of X to the eighth or I should
say four is half of eight so when i
factor this I'm gonna go right to X to
the fourth and X to the fourth because
when you multiply and you have the same
base you add the exponents 4 plus 4
gives us 8 now we just have to say what
two numbers multiply to 12 but add to 7
that's going to be 4 & 3 and if you want
to double check your work you can see
you've got 4x to the fourth 3x to the
fourth which adds up to 7x to the fourth
4 times 3 is 12 and X to the fourth
times X to the fourth is X to the 8th
and you've got it if it was an equation
if it is equal to 0 you can set each
group equal to 0 and then solve if you
want to see a lot more examples about
all different kinds of factoring I did a
video called learn how to factor and it
goes through this type as well as other
types that you need to know in terms of
factoring check out that video I did
right there
subscribe to the channel and I look
forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon